- Thank you all for attending our session
that talks about unstructured data
and different data modalities
and how can you build a
strong foundations for AI.
We're very excited about this session.
We are excited to share
some of our experience
from the real world as well.
And we couldn't be more
thrilled to be here with you.
With me on the stage,
I have Avinash Reddy Erupaka,
who's our speaker from customer side.
He's a leading principal
engineering at Bayer.
I also have Shiv Narayanan.
He's our product lead for
SageMaker Unified Studio.
Throughout our session, we're gonna have,
be looking at multiple demos
as well as some of the
real-world examples.
So thank you, Avinash and Shiv.
So I just wanna start by
asking, how's everyone doing?
I know it's a speaker,
I cannot hear you and all that,
but it's all good.
Thumbs up is good.
So what we have done today
is we have structured our conversation
and story in these five or
four different sections.
We're gonna talk about
a very important topic
called data readiness for AI, right?
We are talking about
unstructured data today,
among other modalities,
but it is important for us to align
and land on this foundation
that talks about how you
build your data platform
which is ready for
agentic AI and workflows
and things like that.
We're also gonna look at
different data modalities.
So my name is Navneet.
I lead the data and analytics for AWS
for life sciences customers.
So most of my examples
are coming from the life sciences world.
Having said that,
a lot of my other partners and colleagues
in the organization work
with different industries.
I see a lot of similarities.
We're gonna talk about that too.
Then we're gonna look in the demos
for Amazon SageMaker Unified Studio,
Amazon SageMaker Governance, that:
how can you build a
platform that can serve
not only structured,
but unstructured data?
And finally, we're gonna hear from Avinash
on the real-world examples,
real-world use cases of Bayer.
I wanna start by this slide,
which I'm sure you all
are very familiar with,
not maybe the slide,
but the concept, right?
So as you know,
that the lot of interest
and a lot of work that is being done
in building generative
AI and AI applications,
and agentic AI applications.
This is a 40,000-feet view maybe.
Of course we are not drilling down.
But if you look at this pyramid,
at the bottom of all this is
the data foundations, right?
And data foundation is
something which is evolving
and changing with the need and, you know,
the kind of modalities that we have
and also the type of
agents that we are writing.
So to write an AI application,
to write agentic AI application,
you need to rely on the data foundations.
And today we're gonna talk
about how you build that,
what are some of the best practices,
what can you use on AWS, as an example.
So again, we're gonna
start with this today.
So a few years back,
there was a paradigm in
data called data mesh.
Have you heard of that?
Some of you might have heard of data mesh.
And it was an interesting
paradigm, actually, very,
very timely at that point
because that was the first time
when someone was building
a paradigm shift on data
that involves people,
process, and governance.
Not that the governance
wasn't done before,
it was done before.
There were MDMs, there
were data governance leads,
and things like that,
but the distribution of data assets
across your organization
was something that data
mesh was targeting,
along with people,
process, and technology.
In last couple of years,
we have seen the same paradigm shift
on the generative AI side, right?
So keep that data mesh concept in mind.
I'll try to merge them together here,
because how can you leverage
your existing platform
in actually serving up your agents?
So we started from traditional AI/ML.
This is an era where
you're writing neural nets,
deep learning models,
machine learning models,
statistical analysis,
regressions, you name it.
And most of the uses there
was you have a notebook
or RStudio or something like that,
which is enabling your data
scientists to run analysis;
and this is the typical.
Now then came the generative AI,
so large language model
building summarization,
building notes,
and building other sort of content
that can be leveraged for your business.
But with the introduction of
generative AI-based workload,
there's another thing that
was very much important
along with the data,
is the context, right?
That's where you have
technologies, RAG and stuff.
Lately we are seeing a lot of interest
and a lot of workloads
that customers running building agents,
which is basically, in my opinion,
a unit of work that gets
a specific business metric
or a specific work done for you.
And we are looking at
multi-agent collaboration now.
So it's not only one agent,
but it's a combination of
agent with orchestration,
with chain-of-thought
reasoning, and all those things,
that is helping you building a workload
that serve up for your business.
And there are several
examples in the space.
What is important when you
think about building data
and you think about building these agents?
The one common theme between the two
is that how are you
utilizing your data platform
to serve up these agents
and how that is any different
from what you were doing previously.
As you see in this slide, at the top,
we have the foundation model,
the models that you would be utilizing
to build those agents, right?
But that alone is not sufficient.
You need enterprise knowledge,
as it says in the bottom of this slide.
So think about the shift in the data,
a paradigm shift with data mesh,
and think about the paradigm
shift in the gen AI, which is,
in this slide we're calling it
multi-agent collaboration or a mesh.
So data is no longer the only product
that you're sharing
across the organization.
You are also sharing
agents and other things.
So AI is only smart as your data.
Like, we all understand that.
And data can be a different type.
Now, this is a life sciences example.
In your organization,
you may be having your existing data,
that is your relational databases,
your warehouses, your S3 data,
your your S3 tables,
or one of our partner solutions.
This data typically is largely structured
and also unstructured.
But largely what we have seen mainly
is that you have rows, columns,
some sort of a packet document,
though stored raw,
but you can query that.
The new data that you're creating...
And this is where we're
seeing a lot of data
which is getting created
in an unstructured way.
In my example
and then Avinash will talk
about that later also,
that a lot of data coming
from these instruments,
the lab instruments,
a lot of data coming from
your genomics information
and gene information,
and other verticals too,
like social networking,
your clinical notes, your images, PDFs,
and things like that,
all the data that you're creating
is largely unstructured, along with...
Now, you have to work with both.
You cannot leave the structured data.
You have to make sure that your guidance
and your implementation
has both of those things.
And then the third-party data.
This is what you acquire
from other partners,
other sources, and things like that.
So how you combine these
different data assets
and spread that in a
data mesh-like setting
with the right pillars
so that you can serve
up your agentic platform
as well as the human usage
and things like that?
An example of a multimodal data science...
Now, even though you're
not, say, for example,
if you're not from the life
sciences/healthcare industry,
it still is very much relevant for you.
At the center of this diagram,
we have somebody called a patient, right?
A patient is someone who
has certain data records
like admissions, discharges,
labs, you know, conditions, procedures.
We all have that, right?
We've all been to different
healthcare facilities
and we have this data.
Now, if you note that,
that you have the EHR data,
which is largely structured,
other than the clinical
notes and the summaries,
but you also have the clinical notes,
the dictation in physician room
or a vaccination data,
or a social/geographic data.
This comprises of a multimodality
in any organization, right?
So you wanna make sure that
as you look at this example,
is that identify the modalities
in your specific lines of business
and identify the
different type of modality
and then create a common model
that can help you govern the data,
that can help help you build the agents
and things like that.
On the right hand side of the patient,
you have the omics data.
Now, this also has a large
volume, like, for example,
microbiome or metabolome or the proteome.
All this data that you have
is largely unstructured
and requires a great deal
of analysis that you need.
Now, you might ask that,
"I've been building my data agents,
I've been building my data platform
for a number of years now.
My data is very good.
I don't have to do anything else.
What is that I need to do to make my data,
unstructured and structured data,
something like what we've
seen in previous slide,
ready for the AI?"
Now, this is a very small example.
On the left, you see,
which is the current state,
which is a state of data scientists,
data engineers interacting with the data.
As you can see,
a researcher investigating
drug interaction
knows where to start: a
database, a molecular database.
They can then go and
understand the significance
of specific protein bindings
and things like that.
So they start with a very
narrow focus approach
and they know exactly
what they're looking for.
Now, you may be having in
the right best possible way,
the right quality, the right access,
and things like that,
and they're good with that.
The challenge: that it
doesn't scale, right?
So if you scale that to hundreds
and thousands of data scientists,
it you scale it to hundreds
and thousands different data models,
chances are you need something
that can help you scale.
Which brings us back on the
other side, which is that,
"Hey, I can write agents
that can go against this data
and really scale it further."
What is the challenge there?
It starts with speculative
exploration, right?
Because you're pretty much throwing
every single data elements to those agents
and then they're doing some...
For example, in this case I have:
"An agent is tasked with analyzing
clinical trial effectiveness,
might initially request all
the available trial data
and then further filter it down."
So, what is the right balance?
And the reason it's important for us
to know it now more than ever
is that when you think
about the right balance
between how much you want
to provide to the agents
and how much you don't want
to provide to the agents,
the data modality plays a big role.
For unstructured data, a lot of data,
something that an agent can
(crackling drowns out Navneet)
the value out of it.
For structured, you may be requiring
far more governance control
and things like that.
So we have these building blocks
that you think about,
again, at a high level.
My colleague is gonna go deeper
into some of these topics.
But if you look at this one,
we are saying that how you
build data ready for AI
using three building blocks, right?
The first building blocks
is contextual information.
So how do you create data ready for AI?
By bringing the right
context to the data, okay?
The right context means several things.
It could mean your enterprise knowledge,
your ontologies, your metadata,
your business metadata,
and things like that.
The second thing that you
need in your data platform
is the tool provisioning.
This is how someone is going
to be accessing your data.
Now, remember data mesh?
They had this concept called endpoints,
data product endpoints.
So data product can be called using an API
or a SQL or something like that, right?
Now you wanna make sure
that your data platform
is ready to be accessible
by different toolings and resources,
something like an MCP server,
something like another agent,
and things like that.
And then finally, the maturity.
Now, this is a bit tricky
because data maturity for structured data
means different things,
for unstructured means different things.
But it doesn't matter
to your data scientist.
Like, they want data to be fully matured.
So as you think about modalities
and unstructured data,
I would highly recommend
that look through these
three different pillars.
Now, just a show of hands.
How many of you are actually utilizing
your business metadata
as the context information
for your data assets?
And I can tell you that the metadata
is one of the largest
wealth of information
outside of your data
that can provide a lot of information
for your agents to work for the, you know,
for your outcomes.
Which is my next slide,
that if you look at the
metadata a few years back,
it was largely treated as documentation.
Like, I remember sitting with my team,
working on metadata,
building data dictionaries.
That kinda explains what data is:
documentation pretty much, right?
You go through multiple word docs,
you go through multiple data dictionary.
Not that it was bad;
very useful, right?
But it was largely a documentation.
Whereas now in the contextual world...
And by the way,
the data context metadata
is just one of the contexts.
There are other contexts,
depending on the industry
that you work with.
Now, in the gen AI era,
metadata is actually an
intelligent amplifier, right?
So you can use metadata
for business context,
your glossaries or enterprise knowledge,
something the data steward can work with;
and the relationship
discovery across domains,
as an example; and, of
course, real-time trust.
So think about your metadata.
And it's even more important
for your unstructured data
because structured data,
I can still query and make
some sense out of it, right,
or I may be having at
least basic information
of the columns that it has.
But for unstructured,
it's largely unknown for me
until I actually tap inside the file
and see what is going on.
So therefore it is more relevant
for you to think about a
contextual information.
So you build your data platform,
have those three pillars.
In the context, start
with business metadata.
So how do you get your unstructured data
ready for for AI, right?
So on this screen,
you see that you have
different types of sources.
Some video transcription is coming,
some plain documentation is coming.
The two things that I
would like you to take
as an outcome of this talk...
Of course it's a complex topic, you know,
as you start working.
I'm not overly simplify any of it.
But the two areas that we will
focusing a lot today is, one,
that how do you build a
unified governance of your data
irrespective of its type
and modality, right?
Even it is structured or unstructured,
your data needs to be
treated the same way,
and so as the agents, for example, right?
And the second thing is,
specifically for unstructured data,
how do you use some of the
capabilities that we have
in Amazon Bedrock and Amazon, you know,
Bedrock Agentcore,
and Amazon SageMaker that it can utilize
to build insights from the data?
Remember, governance is first,
building insight is second.
So those are the two areas
that we uniquely focus today
in regards to unstructured data.
But as you can see,
there could be structured plus
unstructured here as well.
And, of course, in most cases,
like in my patients example,
you have both of them.
And so it's important
for you to understand
that how you can most experience that,
as an example.
So I'm gonna talk a little bit
on the data founding layer,
which is something that,
very much linked with
what I presented earlier
on the three topics.
So you look at the bottom of this layer,
we call it data readiness for AI, right?
This is where you have
the data foundations:
the structured/unstructured,
interoperability,
and things like that.
This is how you store your data:
best performance, cost, modality.
If I have a data in Iceberg,
I would store that in S3
tables, as an example.
If I have data, unstructured data,
store that in S3 general purpose bucket.
If I have warehouse
data or structured data,
I'll store that in RDS
or Redshift warehouse
or something like that.
If I have unstructured,
I'll just simply store
that in my S3 buckets
and then utilize.
But however we store the data
shouldn't guide the
architecture upstream, right?
It's just a storage at the end of the day.
What guides the architecture upstream
is that how you interact with the data.
That's where the
interoperability is very handy.
So it's something like
Iceberg-compatible data,
as an example.
On top of that, to have
your data ready for AI,
you have context, tools, and maturity.
Remember those three pillars?
Context is extremely important
for your agents to work with your data.
Without that,
it's going to be speculative exploration
for the most part, right?
And context is not only business metadata.
There are other things like
clinical ontologies in my world.
In your world, it could
be other ontologies
and enterprise knowledge
and things like that.
You have that platform, then
you start building agents.
So we have agents, in my case,
healthcare/life sciences agents,
but you may be having some agents
which are specific to your industry.
We have, you know, a offering
there which you can use:
the accelerators that our team has built.
You have agentic workflow,
you have data accelerators.
All that, you put in there.
Then you build a governance layer.
FLAIR principle.
Everybody knows what
FLAIR is, I'm assuming:
findable, accessible,
interoperable, reusable.
L is the lineage,
which is also something that we've added
as part of the...
And it's interesting to know
that even lineage can act
as a context to your data:
the provenance, the transformation,
and things like that.
Then after that, you
build an experience layer.
This is your end users.
Like, you, as a developer,
as an IT governance lead,
you're building all this platform
and then you build experience
layer with analytics,
with visualization, and with chat.
Those are the typical three
what I've seen lately:
SQL analysis, notebooks, or
the chat agent experience.
How you do that on AWS?
You have Amazon SageMaker Lakehouse.
This is how you store the
data, structured/unstructured,
federated into existing
sources and things like that.
You have the context as
the ontology, metadata,
knowledge graph.
Your tooling is MCP servers, APIs.
And, of course, the
maturity is the quality.
There are others, of course,
maturity principle that you can follow.
Amazon Bedrock and Agentcore
for running or building your agents
and running or
operationalizing production.
Amazon SageMaker Catalog,
a unified governance model
through which you can
unify your governance
across any type of modalities of data,
including unstructured data.
And then at the top,
you have SageMaker Unified Studio
for building your experience.
You have Amazon SageMaker
Notebooks and Data Agents
to accelerate your development using AI.
And then your Amazon QuickSuite
for you to build a chat agent
experience for your customers.
Really quickly,
I have the sample use
case for digital labs.
This is very healthcare-specific.
The one thing I just wanna call here
is that on the left hand side,
you see there are different
type of instruments
from where the data is coming out, right?
And like I said, every industry
has something very specific
to how they're collecting data.
In my case, it's coming through that.
All that part is not that super important.
What is important
is that it's getting stored
in the storage layer.
Remember the previous
slide where I showed you
the data can be structured/unstructured.
Focus on the storage,
how you store the best.
Don't store your unstructured data
in a relation database.
It's not a good idea.
It's not cost-effective solution, right?
Then we have the lineage,
metadata, catalog,
and the governance built, right?
So just those three pieces.
Start small.
Think big, start small.
You have to refactor everything.
Your environment currently is good enough
for you to build these
components starting now.
Then you have the semantic layer.
Extremely important, the semantic,
which is an extended
concept there of context.
What are the semantics for
my own organizations, right?
In my case, it might be something like:
What is a brain tumor?
What is a diabetes?
And what is something like a carcinoma?
In your world, it could be something else.
The point here is that
you build a semantic layer
and then you build all
these consumption models.
So in a cloud environment,
store data effectively,
build the right context,
and then go on from from there.
So some of the challenges I want call out
before I call upon Shiv.
The challenges in processing
unstructured data.
So far we talked about, you know,
the approach of data foundation
and what is important for readiness
and why unstructured
data needs to be treated
very similar way.
Bt it should also,
it shouldn't drive your
architectural decision drastically.
What are the some of the challenges?
Governance, of course.
The governance of unstructured
data is very different
at the bottom level.
It shouldn't be different
at the top level.
So the findability, the
access provisioning.
The model and tool selection
is a challenge too,
where you have the
selecting optimal solutions
and modality/use cases.
There's a lot of manual
processing for unstructured data,
like data extraction tuning
and parameters and things like that.
And finally, the orchestration.
Managing multiple models for
unstructured data is not easy,
it's a challenge,
output integration is a challenge,
and things like that.
So how do we address these challenges
that can span across
the governance of data
and the usage of it?
For that, I'll call upon my colleague Shiv
to talk about the next portion,
where we'll see some of
the SageMaker capabilities
to address these challenges.
Shiv.
- All right. Hey, folks.
Hopefully you'll be able to hear me.
Great.
So my name is Shiv Narayanan.
I'm a product manager
on the SageMaker team,
the next-gen SageMaker.
So there are two services: SageMaker AI,
which is the machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
The next-gen SageMaker
puts everything together.
How many of you use SageMaker today?
Awesome.
I wanted to actually put up my picture,
but then I figured I might
as well just put somebody
who's from Adobe, you know?
So today my goal is to kind of expand
upon what Navneet said
and show you a bunch of demos
on SageMaker Unified Studio.
So this is Dr. Smith.
And we're gonna be
walking through a journey.
Dr. Smith is a neuro-oncologist
treating brain cancer,
and we are gonna help him
prepare for a meeting tomorrow
with one of his patients.
And one of the patients
he's gonna be meeting
is a 25-year-old person, a female,
who has been recently diagnosed
with a neurological cancer.
And the meeting tomorrow is
super important for Dr. Smith
because that's the first time
that she's actually
meeting with Dr. Smith.
And the most important thing
that Dr. Smith wants to do in that meeting
is to instill hope.
And the way you do that
in the most effective way
is to tell the patient that,
"I've actually seen patients like you.
And I have,
you have hope simply because
we've actually done this
over and over
and there is really light
at the end of the tunnel."
But what he's actually doing right now
is actually to stare at those documents,
the unstructured data, right?
And in those documents,
one of the couple of things
that he's really scared of,
like how you probably
might be also scared of,
is the amount of in incredibly
insightful information
that's scattered across.
And this data changes every
single document he changes.
This is actually the
reality of healthcare today.
And more importantly,
there is demographics data,
there is medications, there is procedures,
there's treatments,
but there is also sensitive data.
Now, it's super important for us
to be able to provide Dr.
Smith the required tools
in order to make sure that
he gains access to this data,
the capabilities to use the
latest generation technologies
like large language models
to help process/parse this
and eventually help him
prepare for this meeting.
And that's what I'm gonna do now.
We, as a team,
are gonna actually go through that
to see how to actually help
him prepare for that meeting.
So in order to do this,
the most important things
is that obviously you have to
have the right AWS services
to do it.
And end of the day,
our goal is to actually
build him a chat agent.
And this chat agent needs to be built
with all the right
governance controls in place.
And traditionally,
it was also a little
difficult in AWS to do this
simply because while
we have all the breadth
of these services,
you have to hop onto different consoles.
So what is the innovation that we've done
in the past year to
simplify these problems?
With that, I wanted to talk a little bit
about the team that I'm
part of and very proud,
of the next-generation SageMaker.
So this is actually your center
for data analytics and AI.
SageMaker is comprised of
three important components.
The first one is the
lakehouse architecture,
where you actually store all
these documents that you saw.
The next one is a catalog.
The ability for you to make sure
that you actually take
all these unstructured
and structured documents,
catalog them, annotate them,
provide the visibility
of data quality metrics,
associate glossary terms.
And you have a unified studio
that allows customers
to build applications
all the way from simple
data engineering pipelines
to extremely complicated
machine learning models
and also chat agents with ease,
all without you having to
switch different consoles.
Before we dive into a
demo of how we do this,
let's just walk through
a little bit more details
about the catalog first.
How many of you use the
SageMaker Catalog today?
Cool.
Very good.
So, what's different
about the SageMaker
Catalog is, first of all,
it's actually built on
DataZone's business data catalog.
It really is built on a very
scalable model to begin with.
The second important
thing about the catalog
is it's just not like a catalog
for structured data assets.
It's a catalog for your
unstructured data assets,
it's a catalog for your
business intelligence assets.
So it's really much more broader
and we continue to enhance
the number of types of objects
that we support on that.
You can also understand
the quality metrics,
you can understand the data
lineage from that catalog.
You can also understand the
ability for you to search.
And you can subscribe to these assets
and gain permissions to data
in an auditable and compliant way.
So that is very unique about
the permissioning model
that has been integrated
with the SageMaker Catalog.
In addition to it,
there are other components
that I'll be talking through my talk
in terms of the guardrails
and the responsible AI aspects
that you'll actually see in a demo also.
So the catalog is an
extremely important component
for Dr. Smith and his team
because as a first step,
what we wanna do is to be able to take
all this unstructured data, catalog them,
make them discoverable,
provide the right guardrails
so that he can actually,
him and his team can actually
get the right access controls.
The next part is: how do
you build your applications?
So that's where we have
the Unified Studio.
So Unified Studio gives you the ability,
in a single console,
to build all required apps
that is needed for your
data engineering work
to the AI work.
For example, if you're a visual person,
if you are like more into
visual ETL development,
we have a visual ETL that
is available for you.
If you are more of
code-based data engineering,
you have notebooks that is embedded in it.
You wanna build machine learning models,
we have foundational models,
we have the SageMaker AI models
that are available in a model hub,
that you can actually
take them, train them,
experiment them with ML flow,
and then deploy them.
And if you're a gen AI developer,
we have the ability
for you to build chat
applications and prompts,
the necessary guardrails,
all of them together.
So that is the Unified Studio.
Now, what we are gonna do
is actually watch a demo,
and I'm gonna walk you through this.
And as a first step
to help Dr. Smith prepare for his meeting,
we are going to take all
this unstructured data
that's already available
in S3, catalog them,
and make sure that it's
actually discoverable.
That's the step number one.
And here's how we are gonna do it.
Before that, let me just quickly walk you
through an important launch that we did
a couple of months ago,
which is the ability for
you to actually catalog
these unstructured assets.
With this, you can connect to S3,
either to a bucket or a folder,
take those assets,
provide business context,
publish those to the data catalog,
and then make it discoverable.
So with that, let's just watch this demo.
So I'm showing you the Unified Studio.
And in here,
what we are gonna do is
to go to the Data tab
of that project.
And as you can see here,
I have my Lakehouse,
which is structured assets,
and then I have Buckets.
I'm gonna go ahead and
connect to my S3 location,
provide a name for the data lake,
provide a description,
specify the URL where the
medication records are stored,
provide a role,
and then we are going to
hit the ability to connect.
So what this does in the backend,
this is actually going to
create a connection to S3
and then it is actually
going to first bring in
all the assets that you actually watched
in the previous screen,
which Dr. Smith was actually staring at.
So these are all the unstructured data
that you were actually seeing.
And these are all the medications
that you just watched in that.
So as a next step, what I'm
gonna do is actually to,
for brevity of this demo,
I'm just gonna go ahead and
catalog the entire bucket.
You can actually catalog
individual folders.
But what we're gonna do is
to add some business metadata
to the structured assets.
So this is the screen
where you can actually add
a whole lot of business metadata.
To begin with,
what I'm gonna do is
to start adding context
in terms of the readme file.
And this is what Navneet talked about:
the context that is needed
for the generative AI purposes, right?
So I've added what exactly
are these documents.
I've provided detailed descriptions,
the type of diagnosis,
the medications that's there.
I'm also associating glossary terms.
So in the catalog,
you have the ability to create a glossary
in a hierarchical way
and then associate terms to these.
This allows you to search
and it also provides
meaningful associations
when your other customers,
who are actually working on SageMaker,
to understand and discover
these assets pretty easily.
So I'm going to go
through a variety of terms
and then select them and
associate them for these assets.
So now that we are happy
with adding all those assets,
let's go ahead and click yes.
And you also have the ability
to extend this metadata
with additional concepts
called metadata forms.
I'm not gonna do that
to keep this demo short.
And let's go ahead and publish this asset.
So when you publish this asset...
So long you've been actually
just kind of working
in your own local copy, so to speak.
When you publish this,
this now is discoverable
by anybody and everybody,
not necessarily the data,
but they can actually view the metadata.
So now I just want to go to the catalog,
make sure that I've actually
published this right.
And you can actually
browse through the assets
and you can see the type of assets,
the glossary terms that I associated.
Very easy for me now to basically say,
"Give me the patient data.
Give me the cancer diagnosis data."
I can go through and look
at different asset types.
You might have seen, like,
the different types of
assets that we support there.
We also provide couple
of other capabilities
and extensions for this.
It looks really great from my perspective
of how I've published metadata.
I also have lineage,
but this is basic data
lineage at this point in time
because we just have started to work.
And as lineage builds up,
it's gonna be built up
pretty well in this.
So what I've done so
far is taken that assets
that was just an S3,
that was not discoverable by anybody,
and I've made them discoverable
at this point in time
for people to come in and start working.
So next,
we are gonna have a generative
AI developer come in
and do some work with this data.
But before that,
let's just look at a few more concepts.
SageMaker Unified Studio
is one of the services
that brings all the structured
and unstructured data together
and allows you to build
knowledge bases with ease.
So we provide the ability,
in one single place,
for you to come in and source structured
and unstructured data
and then easily build knowledge bases
for your gen AI applications.
How many of you have built
a knowledge base in Bedrock?
Cool.
So one of the things...
And I think, like, all of us know...
Navneet talked adequately about RAGs
and what's the usefulness of RAGs.
These are the concepts
or these are the objects
that make your foundational
model more intelligent
and your organization aware, right?
So by using a knowledge base,
what you can do is to enhance
your existing large language models
to provide more context of
your organizational data.
And what we,
from SageMaker Unified Studio
and SageMaker as a whole,
do is to allow for you
to create these knowledge bases with ease,
without having to navigate
through multiple APIs,
just simply with a few click of buttons.
And I'm gonna show you how
you can actually do that.
Now, it's one thing to
have a knowledge base,
but the most important
aspect is even governing
to make sure these models are grounded,
to make sure that it's not hallucinating,
to make sure that it is not being hateful,
to make sure that it is
actually providing the context
or the right data
by looking at the data
that you have provided.
So for this, Bedrock offers guardrails.
With guardrails, what you can do is...
It comes out of the box
with a bunch of filters
that you can apply to make sure
that your models are grounded.
But in addition, you can
also extend them with ease,
with simple natural language,
to make sure that your prompts are,
the result of the large language
models that you're using
is appropriate.
So, for instance,
a couple of things that you
could do is, for instance,
you could say, "Don't
show PII information," or,
"Don't show like," you know,
"I don't want you
to basically be always
grounded with facts."
And you can do a lot with
with with guardrails.
And what is unique about
SageMaker's integration
with guardrails is the
fact that it allows you
to basically take your
data from your catalog,
build that knowledge base,
build that guardrails,
all in one single unified console,
and then be able to deploy these
to your business users with ease.
And that exactly is what
we are gonna do next.
So we have a generative AI developer.
Remember we just cataloged,
as a data producer,
all these assets in our catalog?
As a generative AI developer,
John comes in,
just searches for a term diagnosis.
This is a very common term
that occurs for many people.
They just come and search
and immediately they're
able to discover that asset.
When they discover,
they're able to see the metadata,
they're able to see the glossary terms
that they've associated.
And with a lot of confidence
and discussions with their colleagues,
this is the right data set
that we have to build our knowledge base.
So one thing that John does here
is he's gonna ask for access to that data,
and this is the unstructured data access
that he's requesting for.
So he has requested for that access
and he can actually view that,
that he's actually requested for access.
Now, the data producer gets
this as a notification, that,
"Oh, a generative AI developer
actually has asked me access."
Now, this is at this point in time,
he can click, talk to the legal teams,
make sure that they understand
what the use case is for
this particular asset,
and then approve or reject
this particular access.
So in this case, after
discussions with legal
and other compliance organizations,
they are approving
to make sure that they
can actually go ahead
and build a chat application
or to feed this into a knowledge base.
So now we've gotten John
access to that data.
This is great.
So John goes into his project,
goes to the Data tab,
and now confirms that he now
has access to that S3 buckets,
which is great; he now has access.
So the next natural step is to go ahead
and start building the chat application.
And remember, I talked about two concepts,
the knowledge base and guardrails,
and that's exactly what
we are gonna build.
Look at how easy it is to build that.
With Unified Studio,
you just go in there and
create a knowledge base,
provide the name of the knowledge base,
and what differentiates things here
is the fact that you can
now use the data sources
that you have gotten
access directly from here.
So I just got access to my S3 locations,
I just provide that,
I'm selecting the embeddings I need.
SageMaker Unified Studio takes care
of all the other required components,
like making sure that it
creates a vector database
in Amazon OpenSearch,
which is a serverless offering here,
and makes sure that it
indexes all the data
and creates that knowledge base for you
without you having to
do that heavy lifting.
It's just a few simple clicks.
So, once the knowledge base is created,
the next step for us
is actually to go ahead
and create the guardrails
because this is the governance application
that we need to make sure that, you know,
we are applying the right
governance controls.
And as you can see, out of the box,
there is a whole bunch of filters
that allow you to control the responses
of the knowledge base.
But you can also add your custom
messages or custom prompts
to make sure that you are applying
your own governance controls.
In this case, I don't want anyone here
to prompt for address
information, the demographics.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and create a deny address
and I'm gonna create a definition for it.
So I'm just basically saying like,
"Don't respond.
If there's patient address information,
you can provide some sample phrases."
That's optional for you.
And we are just gonna go ahead
and create this guardrail.
So once the guardrail is created,
once the knowledge base is created,
it's now time for us
to create the chat app.
And again, it's not too difficult.
You simply go to the My
apps, create a chat app.
And here, we provide a
name for the chat app.
In this case, we'll just
say it's Patient 360.
And we select the foundational model.
We now provide the knowledge base
that we want to augment
this foundation model,
which is pretty straightforward
because we created the knowledge
base of the previous step.
We basically select that.
We can apply multiple guardrails.
So we'll just go ahead
and apply that specific guardrail here.
And what we are gonna do
is to save this chat app.
And so
we'll just go ahead and save.
And next step is that...
Now that I've been working on
my local copy in my project,
the most important step
is to actually go ahead
and deploy it so that it's
basically visible to others
and I'm in a position
where I can actually start
sharing this with others.
So we'll just go ahead
and provide a name for it
or the alias name that
represents that certain version
or any changes to that version.
Because it's the first
time I'm just deploying it,
I'm just gonna provide the
right description for this app.
And we just simply deploy that app.
It is pretty straightforward
as you can see.
In few steps,
we basically took the data, got access,
and basically built a knowledge base.
And next step, we can
actually start sharing this.
We're gonna share this
with Dr. Smith; however,
you can also share it with
a group of individuals.
Pretty straightforward in terms
of how you can share this.
And then we just went ahead
and published this app.
So in this demo,
what we have done is
we've shown you, like,
how easy it is for a gen AI developer
to take assets in a very
secure, compliant manner,
in an auditable way,
and take that and create a
knowledge base out of it,
apply the right governance and guardrails,
and then deploy it using
SageMaker Unified studio.
So now is a time when Dr. Smith
comes in after his rounds.
He got an email saying, "Look,
the app is ready, you know, to share.
You can start asking the questions."
So he doesn't click on the link,
instead he goes and discovers that app.
And the app is there.
The first thing that
always prompts us is, like,
to test the app, right, like,
"Oh are you compliant?"
So let's go ahead and say like,
"Hey give the address of
a patient whom I know:
Owen Anderson.
Can I get the address?"
The guardrails kicks in, it says,
"Sorry, I can't give
you that information,"
enforcing that governance controls.
The next thing is I'm happy, as Dr. Smith,
to see that it's actually
a chat application
that's compliant,
but I know of a patient,
let me make sure that I can see
if that patient actually
has that information
that I can validate, right?
Like, is the data right?
So he basically asked like,
"Okay, tell me something
about Own Anderson."
The chat app is able to use
the knowledge base we created
and rightly summarize that
information in a very clean way.
The next thing, getting more confident,
he asks another question:
"How many patients are
there with brain cancer?"
He uses just a very simple term,
not even, like, anything
like oligodendroglioma,
none of that, just a simple brain cancer.
The chat app, with the help
of large language models,
is intelligent enough to
understand the context
with all the metadata that we are provided
and provide, like,
really solid responses
interacting with a physician,
a neuro-oncologist, which
is, I think, pretty cool.
And now he basically says like,
"Look, I have a meeting tomorrow
with a 24-year-old patient.
She's a female.
Find me patients like her.
And tell me the number
of comparable patients.
What is the histology of those patients?
Tell me, like,
what kind of treatments
they've gone through.
And just be grounded with facts.
Don't hallucinate," right?
Like, he's kind of prompting the system.
And the model really behaves well.
It basically gets that data,
provides the necessary information.
It says like, "Look, I found
a patient similar to her.
She's on this protocol,"
and all kinds of information.
Again, all of this is synthetic
data that we manufactured.
I can only imagine, you know,
if you start using it on your real data,
I'm sure you'll get pretty
good results of this.
But at this point,
Dr. Smith is able to get
the required responses
that he wanted
and he's ready to prepare for his meeting
and he's ready to go for tomorrow.
So I know we took a healthcare example.
You may all be from different industries,
but in every part of your journey
there is SageMaker there to help you,
help accelerate through that journey.
And I'm hoping that after the talk
you will go and you will try
out SageMaker Unified Studio
or Catalog.
And we just can't wait to
hear what you do with that.
With that, I wanted to
invite our customer speaker,
Avinash, from Bayer,
to tell you how they're
actually doing these things
in real world at Bayer.
And thank you very much.
(crowd chattering)
(attendees applauding)
- Good afternoon, everyone.
Can you guys hear me okay?
Wonderful.
I'm Avinash Erupaka.
I'm a principal engineering
lead at Bayer Pharmaceutical.
So Bayer is 150-year-old
life sciences organization
that is driven by the
mission of health for all,
hunger for none.
We operate across different
life science verticals
combining crop science,
consumer health, and pharmaceutical.
So today I'm here to talk
about one of the biggest challenge
that we have in modern-day drug discovery,
that is data fragmentation
and contextualization.
For decades,
search for new therapies has
been a race against time,
with massive investments pouring into R&D.
But one of the biggest
non-scientific challenge
that we have is not the
complexity of biology,
but our ability to leverage existing data
and accelerating AI.
Data that's trapped in silos
slows down our scientists
and bog down critical decision making.
We, our mission,
our team's mission is
very straightforward.
We are here to break down the silos,
unlock speed, trust, and scale.
When the data is locked
in silos, we lose speed.
When compliance, lineage,
and consent are not clear, we lose trust.
And without platform-level patterns,
we cannot scale.
So the vision that we have
for our Bayer data science ecosystem
is a platform built on the principles
of distributed data mesh,
along with analytical and AI workbenches
plus a central governance
spine and a central catalog.
We operate across vital data domains,
like omics, clinical, chemistry,
and we operate in a distributed
data mesh architecture.
Think of DSE as a supply chain fabric
that connects data and AI across R&D.
In a data mesh architecture,
the ownership of these data domains
is federated to the data owners.
For example, the biomarker
team owns the biomarker data,
the omics team owns the sequencing data,
so on and so forth,
while the central platform
manages the the interoperability
and scalability of the platform.
Our team solves these
cross-cutting concerns
by providing turnkey
solutions around data ops,
AI/ML ops, cost hygiene,
observability, monitoring,
and also validated reusable templates
by removing all the
infrastructural concerns
that bog down our scientists,
where our practitioners,
like machine learning researchers,
bioinformaticians, biostatisticians,
can focus 100% of their time on science
and not service.
And the glue that brings
all of this together
is SageMaker Unified Studio.
SageMaker Unified Studio
acts as a central
governance control plane,
a front door,
where it enables all of the capabilities
and enables these data
domain owners to engineer
and publish these assets into the catalog.
These assets are unstructured S3 tables,
structured S3 assets,
analytical assets like
machine learning features,
machine learning models,
inference endpoints, agents,
so on and so forth.
So the seamless integration
where these distributed data domains
kind of merge into a unified catalog
is what enables the holy grail of R&D,
which is multimodal analytics.
So just to quickly...
Quick raise of hands.
How many of you are dealing
with multimodal data
at your organizations?
Great. Great.
So search for new therapies
is fundamentally a multimodal challenge.
In order for us to understand a disease,
drug mechanism of action,
and how a patient is responding,
we cannot look at this data in isolation.
So if you look at a critical
domain like oncology,
approximately 80% of the data
across key therapeutic areas
is multimodal in nature.
None of this would be possible if we have,
our data is in silos, okay?
Our internal biomarker archive,
a terabyte-scale of
valuable study-specific data
is a clear example.
It was trapped in silos, hard
to access, barely findable,
and generally slowing down the boat.
So the challenge we had at
hand was to handle the scale
by still maintaining the
regulatory compliance
and dealing with these
multimodal capabilities
that we are planning to deliver.
So the solution is a three-step process.
The first step is where
we start by ingesting
our on-prem biomarker data
into S3 study-specific buckets.
Then we enable the trust layer.
Because this data is GXP in nature,
we enable automated ALCOA+ data controls,
making this data attributable, legible,
contemporaneous, original, and accurate.
And we achieve this entirely
by AWS-native controls.
Trust.
By using S3 object locking mechanism
in compliance mode,
we ensure immutability of this data,
critical for regulatory compliance.
Security.
With S3 server-side encryption with KMS,
we ensure our data is at rest.
By leveraging S3 access grants,
we make sure that there
is a tight boundary
of authentication and
authorization controls
that are in place.
Auditability.
By leveraging versioning and CloudTrail,
we make sure the
technical lineage of data,
how the data is accessed is captured,
which is critical for GXP data.
The second step is where our
automation engine picks up.
So our automation engine gets into action
by provisioning all the
infrastructure peripherals
and the components like
SageMaker Unified Studio
and its underlying components
for the study projects.
And then it starts off by
creating an authentication
and authorization boundary
by leveraging the S3 access grants
and directly mapping
them to these projects.
Third step is where we register
the study specific-unstructured
S3 locations
as assets into the catalog,
immediately making it
findable and self-describing.
Through this process,
we also capture multifaceted metadata,
administrative metadata in
terms of data ownership,
data access, licensing needs of the data,
and also domain and
asset-specific metadata
with rich business
contextual metadata tags,
creating a control layer,
making this data ready for AI.
We also...
Then the third phase
is where the closed-loop
execution comes into the picture.
Now users start acting on
this secured, governed data.
The AI consumers now consume this data
from the central catalog in
a secured, governed manner,
and they will start
engineering additional assets
by leveraging this data.
These assets can be
cross-study fact tables
by exploring dimensional data,
which is critical for
future consent management.
AI consumers can also produce
additional analytical assets
like machine learning models,
machine learning features,
agents, et cetera,
and in turn,
all of these assets are
published back into the catalog.
So this powerful phenomena
of closed-loop execution
where you consume
and produce back into the same catalog
really creates a lineage-driven
closed-loop execution,
which helps us answer question
not only who has access to this data,
but what is part of this data packet.
It helps us to track
the journey of the data
from a raw file,
from a raw unstructured file to a model,
really solving the provenance
concerns of a model.
None of this would be possible, you know,
if we were operating in
a siloed environment.
This truly unleashes the
capability of AI and agentic AI
in the space of R&D.
To demonstrate this,
I wanna showcase a real-time,
high-value agentic AI use
case that we are pursuing
in the space of biomarker
data engineering.
So one of the challenge
in early clinical trials
is time to harmonize data.
The ability for us to get data
from our laboratory
information management systems,
from our clinical systems,
running it through data
engineering pipelines,
QCing data is a week-long
effort, manual effort,
critically impacting
our go/no-go decisions.
So we deployed an agentic AI solution,
that's deployed on Bedrock,
which automates this
biomarker data ETL process.
So first,
the agent starts off by
gathering information
from our laboratory information
management system, LIMS,
our clinical systems,
and our study specific data.
Then next it starts to
parse this information.
The agent leverages LLM
that is fine-tuned on vector
indexed on internal protocols and SOPs,
and it starts to parse this
data and identify the patterns.
Second.
Third, the agent not
only acts, but, you know,
it orchestrates the whole flow,
where it picks the right
data engineering pipeline,
biomarker data engineering pipeline,
and engineers the product
and QCs the metrics.
The final step is a result
of a strategic asset
where we have a multidimensional
biomarker data cube
that is further published
into the catalog,
which is very valuable
for further analysis.
So as an outcome,
here we are able to remove
weeks' long worth of manual effort.
We are able to really accelerate
the time to harmonize data
for pharmacokinetic and
pharmacodynamic analysis,
in turn accelerating
our proof of mechanism
and go/no-go decisions,
which is very critical for
clinical trial success.
We are also leveraging
patient data in real time,
understanding the drug response,
improving our success of clinical trials.
So this closed-loop
architecture really provides us
the much-needed value unlocking that we do
in terms of, you know,
trust, speed, and scale.
Beyond the quantitative benefits,
this architectural shift
also delivers, you know,
quantifiable business value
in terms of capturing
multifaceted metadata,
technical metadata
guaranteed by S3 versioning
and CloudTrail logs and
closed-loop execution.
We are exactly able to track
the journey of the data
and exactly answer who
has access to this data.
With rich business metadata tags
and contextual information
that we are capturing,
plus the cross-study fact tables,
we are able to answer which data
is actually used for this analysis.
Let's say in case of
a consent-based study,
a patient pulls consent, we are able to,
the system is able to determine
exactly which part of
the analysis is impacted,
which is critical for
consent-based reusability.
Our roadmap is very clear.
We intend to expand our ecosystem
by onboarding more data domains,
industrialize our AI use cases,
and truly explore the potential
of multimodal analytics
by impacting our pipeline,
optimizing the cost and time that it takes
for bringing critical
life-saving therapies
to our patients.
In closing,
our journey of migrating
a 300-terabyte unstructured data
which is stuck in an on-prem environment
and turning into an
AI-ready strategic asset
is not just a technology story,
it is a story about empowering science.
We have turned an asset
that was barely accessible,
barely findable,
and accessible only through friction,
and turned it into a strategic AI asset
which could streamline
our pipeline activities,
it could improve efficiency
of our R&D decision making,
and overall laying a solid foundation
for our future precision
medicine activities.
So with this, I thank
you all for tuning in.
So feel free to let us know your feedback
so we can improve
and deliver more talks of this sort.
Thank you very much.